bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi à 2
décembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
votre actualité locale accompagné de
nous inviter mais aussi des journalistes
de la rédaction
tout de suite on commence avec les
titres de cette édition alors que mardi
matin une tête de cochon était
découverte devant la mosquée des
quevillais nous recevons ce soir a
déclaré mike farès il mama guyancourt il
nous dira comment la communauté
musulmane réagi actuellement aux
amalgames et l'évoquera les inquiétudes
qu'elle éprouve ils veulent s'engager
l'armée constate une hausse du nombre de
potentiels volontaire alors que
d'habitude on enregistre environ 500
demandes par jour
ce nombre est passé à plus de 1500
depuis le 13 novembre
et c'est dans ce contexte que noël
approche malgré tout nous verrons qui
l'on pourra décider d'illuminer à
nouveau ses rues après plusieurs années
d'économies autre initiative la société
ce qui vous vient de distribuer des
jouets pour les associations caritatives
du territoire et enfin nous
intéresserons au calendrier de l'avent
plus que jamais tendance et une semaine
après les attentats à une semaine
plusieurs semaines après l'attentât de
paris oscille de recrutement de l'armée
de terre connaît un afflux inédit de
visiteurs plus de 1400 internautes
connectés chaque jour sur s'engager
point fr contre 200 à 300 en moyenne ces
derniers mois a précisé le bureau du
recrutement pour en parler avec nous en
direct par téléphone le colonel bruno
même brûlot baer en charge du
commandement du regroupement de
recrutement et de sélection d'île de
france et d'outre-mer
bonsoir alors on sera à vous et merci de
répondre à notre question cette
augmentation justement de volonté à la
sueur de la constater également dans les
yvelines
oui tout à fait cette augmentation dans
une église
puisque tu mois on nous vend pas mal
autour
trois fois plus de contacts dans nos
centres urbains alors qu'ils sont ceux
qui souhaitent justement intégrer
l'armée sur les attentats de paris du 13
novembre dernier et est ce que vous avez
justement besoin de ces candidatures ah
oui ils valent ont besoin de ces
candidatures puis je suis comme common
férié les plus jeunes la république a
décidé d'augmenter de 11000 n la force
d'être ici 2016 et ces jeunes qui
viennent en tout ça à part comme
infections tous besoin de français qui
ont entre 17 ans et demi trente ans et
qui sont motivés pour servir leur pays
et en particulier ceux qui disent qu'il
met en avant depuis les attentats du 13
heures en fait de vous manquer des
transferts l'idée de ce roman qui est
justement voilà il est raciste après
l'émotion ses détracteurs comme que vous
retenez dont vous avez besoin malaisie
les jeunes qui viennent qu'il se
présente à la porte du centre de
recrutement via ni tous avec leurs
motivations et que je les dis mais qu'on
avance cette volonté de faire de notre
pays
les ensuite il rentre dans mon processus
de sélection qui se déroule en quatre
étapes
première étape est de contacter une
étape ensuite d'évaluation de leur
qualité et puis enfin il est à
d'orientation on doit faire mûrir leur
souhait la volonté de rentrer à la
montée en 1re en réalité en faisant
correspondre avec multiples faisons
notre arme père très bien merci beaucoup
à bruno baer pour à ces précisions nous
suivrons bien sûr allez vous cette
actualité et ce soit merci et ce soir
justement en plateau nous recevons abdel
karim aït farès imam de guyancourt et
conférencier bonsoir à vous et merci
d'avoir accepté un autre invitation
alors il ya quelques semaines après les
attentats de paris
la communauté musulmane est victime d'un
amalgame selon les chiffres de
l'observatoire national contre l'islam
l'islamophobie du conseil français du
culte musulman 25 actes anti-musulmans
lui en france depuis les attentats dont
cette agression c'est beaucoup et dans
les yvelines
une tête de porc a été retrouvé hier
devant la mosquée des que vit alors
justement la montée de l'islamophobie et
vous y êtes confrontés est ce qu'on l'a
constaté ici aussi à guyancourt
tout d'abord je vous remercie pour cette
invitation le sentiment tout d'abord des
musulmans c on est encore sous le choc
de ces événements la face à cette
barbarie il ya eu une indignation une
condamnation sans équivoque de tous les
musulmans de france
malheureusement on est il les premières
victimes c'est les hommes et les femmes
qui sont tombés suite à ces actes
barbares
mais les victimes indirectes sont les
musulmans aujourd'hui donc il s'agit
d'actes d'islamophobie
ou bien d'un mal gamme qui fait par
certaines personnes à mélanger entre ces
gens qui ont ces terroristes qui ont agi
au nom de l'islam et de mettre tous les
musulmans dans le même sac
aujourd'hui on dénombre pas
sur la commune de guyancourt des actes
d' islamophobie
mais on va dire sur les yvelines et en
france il y à bien des gens qui ont fait
des témoignages au ccf à ces
organisations qui sont là pour défendre
les droits des musulmans contre
l'islamophobie
effectivement aujourd'hui on est on à 7
contre la cette crainte parce que il ya
des femmes voilées qui ont été agressés
barbe et verbalement des hommes
également qui sont agressés parce que
ils portent là bas parce que ils sont
musulmans
ça c'est du en fait à la désinformation
et l'amalgamé qui est fait et le mélange
entre l'islam et ses terroristes qui ont
agi au nom de l'islam malheureusement
est justement aux fidèles vous parle
justement de sa de leur inquiétude qu
est ce que vous leur dites qu'on vous
leur expliquons réagir justement 1 par
rapport à ça d'une part de faire preuve
de compréhension du parce que c'est à
nous les musulmans de montrer le le vrai
les vraies valeurs
la vraie image de l'islam que l'islam
est une religion de paix d'amour de
miséricorde que tous les musulmans à la
quasi totalité est pas la majorité
écrasante des musulmans en france aspire
à vivre en paix avec ses voisins
aujourd'hui et comme on peut le
constater sur la caricature
aujourd'hui dahesh la deuxième surtout
c'est que aujourd'hui on essaie de
couper le pont entre les musulmans
français et en france et nos concitoyens
dont classe est qualificatif qui montre
bien qui a une cohésion sociale entre
les voisins l'un qui ramène le thé notre
caramel est croissant aujourd'hui ces
terroristes des essais de couper ce
point là donc ne tombons pas dans la
malle gamme donc je fais appel d'une
part à
aux musulmans de faire preuve de sang
froid et de compréhension d'essayer avec
amour et paix et avec la bonne parole
d'expliquer aux gens que l'islam n'a
rien à voir avec ce genre d'acte barbare
pour vous c'est leur rôle lien devoir de
citoyen de bien sûr là est d'une part la
condamnation
d'autre part c'est la ville dans la vie
de tous les jours de montrer à son
voisin à ses collègues de travail à
l'école à tous les niveaux et le serment
de la semaine dernière était sur quelle
image nous renvoyant en tant que
musulmans à nos concitoyens nous disant
ne prenons que l'islam c'est l'islam des
valeurs faut qu'on le montre réellement
à travers notre comportement à travers
nous échanges à travers le dialogue et
l'ouverture à nos concitoyens qui de
certains ne connaissent pas ils ont
juste cette image que certains badié
médias véhiculent vous reste un message
d'unité que vous véhiculez vendredi 27
novembre que vendredi dernier le conseil
français du culte musulman a organisé
une réunion unitaire les représentants
des différents courants de l'islam de
france se sont retrouvés à l'institut du
monde arabe pour débattre et condamné
fermement les récents attentats mais
surtout tenter de trouver une réponse au
terrorisme
il ya une nécessité de signifier
justement pour les musulmans de france
plus que jamais aujourd'hui les
musulmans de france doivent s'unir et
être tous et toutes
derrière un comité qui soit
représentatif de tous les musulmans de
france et qui sera là pour défendre
leurs droits et parler en or no donc
aujourd'hui on a besoin d'une union on
exactement il ya des instances
représentatives
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le cfcm ce qu'on
reproche au cf seb
une bonne partie des musulmans de france
ne s'identifie pas à cette instance
représentatif
nous voulons une instance représentative
qui ne soit pas politique ou qui a des
mains derrière qui viennent de nos pays
d'origine que ce soit une instance qui
représente les musulmans français et de
france est-ce que voilà c'est une étape
à ce que cela va changer vers marque un
tournant a peut-être pour l'organisation
de l'islam en france
ce que nous vivons en ce moment je pense
si nous devons prendre des leçons à
traverser l'heureux événement
c'est bien bien ça cela que ce soit pour
la communauté musulmane
que ce soit pour les hommes politiques
que ce soit pour les autorités de
trouver des solutions pour pouvoir
s'unir et surtout les musulmans de
trouver un cas pour vous dire voilà nous
sommes présents nous font partie
intégrante de la société
nous devons être des musulmans à part
entière et non entièrement à part nous
devons participer à la vie politique
sociale etc et montrer à nos concitoyens
nous sommes des hommes et des femmes
quand vous inspirant nous avons notre
travail nos enfants il nous aspirons à
vivront en paix et on adéquation avec
tous nos concitoyens
donc là c'est un message de tolérance
mais vous comprenez peut-être que
certains musulmans soient en colère
quand ils sont victimes d'un amalgame ou
forcément peut-être d'agressions avec
l'état d'urgence notamment il ya des
responsables musulmans qui ont protesté
contre les perquisitions parfois
abusives vous quelle est votre opinion
par rapport à ça mon opinion
vu l'état d'urgence oui pour les
perquisitions se sont justifiés et fait
de manière en respectant le droit et la
dignité des gens perquisitionné ce qui
est quand même déjà des témoignages et
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur a
dit qu'ils ne toléreraient pas de la
justice ni ni de bavure à ce niveau là
dopent la crainte c'est que ça se passe
dans les règles de l'art sens on s'en f
effrayés les enfants ou que la personne
perquisitionnée soit on va dire traités
de manière indigne devant sa famille ses
proches
merci a déclaré m une dernière question
avant de nous quitter justement pour
lutter contre les algues et ces
amalgames est ce que vous allez mettre
en place des initiatives à guyancourt
par ex dont je pense que nous devons en
tant que responsables d'associations et
de mosquées mettre en place des
initiatives qui nous permettent à
s'ouvrir chênois du en cours on va
organiser des journées portes ouvertes
pour que nos concitoyens les voisins
viennent à la mosquée doive partagent un
thé avec nous et posent leurs questions
nous sommes nous serons
ouvert l'événement sera organisé d'ici
la fin de l'année une date sera précisée
l'objectif c'est d'ouvrir la porte et
d'accueillir tous les concitoyens
quelles que soient leurs origines et
leur religion pour débattre sur les
sujets poser des questions et lever les
amalgames
je finirai par cette phrase là qui vient
de martin luther king qui dit nous
devons apprendre à vivre ensemble
sinon nous mourrons comme des idiots
merci beaucoup karim ait fana
merci d'avoir répondu à la question est
devenue emplacement est aujourd'hui dans
ce journal nous vous proposons nous
proposons de découvrir un témoignage
rare jean baptiste gressens est un des
derniers combattants de la france libre
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale et il
réside à plaisir en novembre il s'était
rendu à la journée de défense et de
citoyenneté de la ville pour échanger
avec des jeunes camille lambert et
jérémy quesada sont allés à sa rencontre
pour en savoir plus sur son parcours de
combattant volontaire
c'est avec ce casque que jean baptiste
gressins servi aux côtés des anglais
dans la royal air force en 1942 à 95 ans
il se rappelle les ordres comme si
c'était hier
lascorz bailloeul colette morte parce
que c'est comme ça les arrangerait pas
si on part du pied gauche bien entendu
anciens combattants de la seconde guerre
mondiale pour les forces françaises
libres
jean baptiste gressins est un évadé de
france partis de paris pour le sud de la
france libre en 1940 il passe en espagne
dans l'espoir de rejoindre l'angleterre
mais capturés par les autorités
il est envoyé dans une maison de
détention la difficulté est peut-être au
point de vue sanitaire c'est vraiment
très déplorable y avait un siège à leurs
trucs pour tous tous pour nous tous de
l'eau une heure par jour dans une petite
cour de cette maison et pour boire et
faire de toilettes toilettes est un bien
grand mot
on était une case et à 1h d'auch d'avec
à un robinet s'est pas beaucoup
après quelques mois jean baptiste
gressins réussi à se rendre à alger où
un centre de recrues
comment des forces françaises libres
accueille les volontaires alors âgé de
21 ans le jeune combattant apprend
l'aviation dans les bases militaires
anglaise de salouël et sutton bridge on
apprenait à faire ou à voler avec un
bimoteur ensuite à faire du bombardement
et de l'instruction que navigations
d'entraînement au sol ce que j'ai fait
c'est la surveillance de sous-marins à
partir de sa bride
car aussi bizarre que ça puisse pareil
quand on est en l'air asu marasme même
en plongée ça se distingue assez
facilement
la guerre terminée jean baptiste fait
carrière dans l'aéronautique
aujourd'hui il habite à plaisir et parle
de son expérience avec les plus jeunes
le 10 novembre il était à la journée de
défense et citoyenneté de plaisir un jeu
de témoignages auquel il se prête
volontiers ça c'est grâce à l'éducation
j'ai reçus pour moi ce la france et
c'est vivant et je suis toujours prêt à
donner et c'est arrivé un plaisir pour
moi de donner pour son engagement jean
baptiste a aussi reçu une dizaine de
distinction les ailes de la france libre
en angleterre et la médaille des
vétérans décerné par le ministère de
l'air britannique orne encore sa veste
mais son plus grand héritage c'est son
histoire un récit qu'il a cristallisé
dans un ouvrage personnel afin de
laisser une trace de son expérience et
noël approche à la ville d'elancourt a
décidé de réinstaurer les illuminations
de noël pour quinze ans après les avoir
supprimées pendant deux hivers de
structures lumineuses géantes ont été
inaugurées comme vous pouvez le voir
hier à la mairie de la commune et dans
le centre commercial 17 mar coût total
de ces led 120000 euros le maire de la
ville jean michel fourgous était au
micro de michele n'aideront
pour nous en tout cas oui parce qu'on
avait freiné avant donc du coup que du
coup et là on entend bien anticipé je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on a un peu de
marge de manoeuvre mais on peut rien
promettre sur ce domaine aujourd'hui on
l'a fait et on est très contents puis
les gens les gens sont satisfaits ils
étaient ils étaient très demandeurs les
deux années où la plus primée sign of
aussi des commentaires c'est normal donc
on enregistre on est là aussi pour
écouter tout le monde et on en a fait ce
qui te venge sur dix points de la ville
vous avez communication significative et
depuis hier vous faites peut-être partie
des chanceux français qui ouvre chaque
matin leur calendrier de l'avent alors
chacun et ce n'est pas toujours facile
de choisir il y a les traditionnels ceux
avec les chocolats ce avec des jouets ou
encore ce que l'on peut faire soi même
ou à des amis
retour sur cette tradition avec mélanie
poker on saura alors au 19e siècle ont
donné des images pieuses aux enfants
c'était le moyen de les faire patienter
jusqu'au 24 décembre
le premier calendrier comme on le
connaît aujourd'hui il date de 1920 et
les premières surprises en chocolat elle
c'est en 1958 nous sommes allés à votre
rencontre pour savoir quelles étaient
vos calendriers comment s'est fait
enfant ça pas tellement changé nous
sommes par rapport à ce qu'on trouve
maintenant on peut on peut voir tout ce
qu'on veut perdre des petits objets puis
avoir des friandises mais mon favori
c'est assez
c'était autrefois c'était plus simple au
jeux le souvenir de mon premier noël où
je ne le croyais plus au père noël
voilà celui là oui ça je m'en souviens
mais après les autres calendriers non je
n'ai pas de souvenir particulier ces
gens n'avaient tous les ans mais après
faisait lesquels je pourrais pas je
pense pas j'en ai eu
fabriqué par un parent face à moi ça me
dit rien en tout cas le 31 mai
exactement maman avait mis tant la
petite boîte du talc pour qui la neige
le chocolat reste la plus grande
tradition il y en a pour tous les goûts
et pour toutes les bourses
le secteur s'est élevé à environ 387
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
pour l'année 2014
je me suis rendu dans une grande
enseigne commerciale ou les calendriers
des marins
moins d'un euro et peuvent aller jusqu'à
plus de 20 euros écoutez alberto mena il
est responsable dans cette enseigne
on continue à avoir bombardé un 13e et
les traditionnels l'établissement s'est
il ya encore des déchirures et
chrétienne il a des graisses ap on part
aussi sur les licences des licences sont
tous les calendriers avec durée voir des
images 3d de distribution des bandes
dessinées s'intéresser à des personnages
et que son vol à la télévision comme les
cas de viol étendue concerne pas le dire
et après il ya ce qui s'appelle les
chocolats de marque alors le chocolat
est toujours le grand gagnant de cette
tradition avec plus de 1,2 million de
calendrier vendu l'an dernier par
exemple mais il ya d'autres types de
calendrier alors avec des jouets des
figurines d'une marque danoise a très
connus ou alors des calendriers que l'on
peut réaliser soi-même et florales
il ya même des calendriers pour adultes
les enseignes de com de cosmétiques en
propose plusieurs avec des prix aux
alentours de 40 euros et peuvent aller
jusqu'à plus de 80 euros cette année il
ya même un calendrier de l'avent
contenant de la bière ou celui avec des
jouets pour adultes
on peut aussi créer son propre
calendrier il faut laisser libre cours à
son imagination
dernière solution le calendrier avec des
cases vides à remplir
ils peuvent être en bois ou aussi en
tissu et on peut y glisser des bonbons
des toupies dépit et bien d'autres
choses
écoutez vincent le montre et gérant
d'une boutique de jouets traditionnels
sur montigny le bretonneux
il ya également cesser ces petits des
petites des petits d'autres types de
personnages qu'on peuvent être pas
forcément chocolat et pour ça on a
besoin d'eux le calendrier de l'avent
qu'ils soient qui qui sont un peu plus
présent dans le temps cette année je le
remarque est plus que parce que
d'habitude
j'ai eu beaucoup de gens qui recherchait
juste des petites choses pour mettre
dans le calendrier de l'avent je leur
proposais mon quartier de la voir il me
répondait avec ces gentils mais non moi
je le fais cette année et cette année ce
qui se sont arrachées ces petits tandis
laure est bien connu ce sont ceux d'une
certaine saga dont le septième volet
sort le 16 décembre c'est des
calendriers qui ne sont pas pour
déplaire à deux membres de notre
rédaction je ne citerai donc pas
wilfried riche et notre rédacteur en
chef et mickaël millero notre
journaliste ben sportif qui a bien
entamé le sien ils sont restés tous les
deux de grands enfants
merci beaucoup mélanie et moi je n'ai
toujours pas de calendrier de l'avent
dont elle est si quelqu'un peut me faire
un petit cadeau on reste sur les jouets
c'est une course au jouet pour les
associations qui s'est déroulée cet
après midi à guyancourt
le bus de noël était stationné cet après
midi devant la maison de quartier
théodore monod pour apporter 40 mètres
cubes de jouer l'opération organisée
parce qu'ils eussent visant à rassembler
des jouets pour les redistribuer à des
associations caritatives est un succès
puisqu'il en est à sa 19e édition
le conseil municipal des enfants de
billancourt a également participé à la
récolte et a pu assister à cette
redistribution assez particulière
puisque le premier arrivé est le premier
servi
le bus a circulé dans les écoles pour
que les parents et les élèves
les enfants donnent leurs jouets et puis
nous avons stationner l'autobus de 12
mètres de long au près du centre
commercial de saint quentin et il ya
même des parents qui ont acheté des
jouets au centre commercial et une
longue mais ils ont rapporté c'est une
journée importante aussi pour les
associations parce que tout est regroupé
dans la salle que nous apprêter monsieur
le maire de guyancourt
comme l'ont fait chaque année dans une
mairie différents dans une commune
différente de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin les
joies ils sont un petit peu rêveur tout
seul parce que on a demandé des jouets
pas casser pas abîmer pas de peluches
enfin certains trucs et même s'ils en
ont donné c'est toujours un acte de
solidarité une action de solidarité
enfin quelque chose qui fait plaisir de
voir que même en période de crise tout
le monde peut donner et que même les
enfants peuvent avoir un petit impact
sur cette redistribution les
associations qui je le rappelle
redistribueront ensuite s'est joué à des
familles dans le besoin
et alors que la coop 21 se déroule en ce
moment même au bourget en france en
parallèle la fédération française de
randonnée yvelines a lancé
et cela dès le mois de novembre une
opération appelée à devenir annuel la
rando net alors le but est d'alerter et
d'étudier le public à la propreté des
balades de la région nous avons suivi
les randonneurs de la ville d'elancourt
au pas de course ils ont nettoyé les
chemins qu'ils ont l'habitude de
parcourir un reportage de fans et
bourdillon camille lambert pour les
images alliés propreté et randonnées
c'est l'objectif de la rando net toute
nouvelle randonnée de 12 km menée par
l'association loisirs et sports
d'elancourt nous avons la chance sur les
encours à proximité des recours d'avoir
des lieux
quand on parcourt les sentiers vieux
chemin est replongé dans un milieu rural
est bon on se fait en quelque sorte que
le milieu urbain si vous voulez ne
pollue pas le milieu dans lequel on a
plaisir à se déplacer munis de sacs et
de gants à trentaine de participants
s'élancent sur les chemins balisés de la
ville
car à chaque cochon canettes mégots et
boîtes de conserve les sacs se
remplissent vite mais chez ces
randonneurs élan pour toi on n'a pas
attendu cette opération spéciale pour
prendre soin de l'environnement en
général dans toutes nos randonnées il ya
toujours des gens pour ramasser quelque
chose qui trait
on s'est naturellement quand j'étais
sollicité j'ai dit oui tout de suite
parce que toute façon ça va rentrer dans
dans les habitudes des bords d'honneur
de garder la nature propre et donc voilà
comment on fait partie de la fédération
française de randonnée on n'a pas hésité
cette opération sera renouvelée chaque
année prochaine randonnée taille
l'encours en avril 2016 et un mois de
sport pour finir avec ce jeune talent à
suivre et sera peut-être le futur
sebastien vettel ou encore à lewis
hamilton
le jeune yves binois de 13 ans william
bertrand affole les compteurs dans les
compétitions de karting son portrait et
si mickaël hay et demi d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude
oui à bertrand 13 ans et déjà un as du
volant sans permis en poche
ce jeune sportif néo chez n'est fait
aujourd'hui partie des trois meilleurs
jeunes pilotes de kart de l'hexagone
dans la catégorie cadet un sport qu'il a
démarré en 2011 aux racines carte de
corneille
c'est mon père un jour on est allé faire
un tour en location et j'ai beaucoup
aimé ça et donc depuis vanhée aller plus
loin et on avait la compétition et c'est
une grande passion donc c'est pour ça
que j'en fais ça me fait très plaisir
d'en faire depuis cette saison la
carrière du jeune prodige s'est
accélérée où liam bertrand remporté le
sens trophy 2015 a terminé à la deuxième
place au championnat d'île de france
au total willy a réalisé huit podiums
sur les douze courses qu'il a disputées
cette saison et une grande maîtrise il a
une grande intelligence de la course il
arrive à maîtriser les compétitions à
savoir se repositionner pendant la
course
récemment dans un championnat de france
et où il fallait faire attention à la
gestion des pneumatiques il a su
justement ne pas toujours attaquer à la
limite pour pouvoir préserver la machine
et espérer être mieux dans la fin de la
compétition pour s'améliorer le jeune
prodige s'entraîne en moyenne un jour
sur cinq sur le bitume du circuit
d'angerville le pilote fans de sébastien
loeb et de vettel pratique également la
natation la course à pied des séances de
musculation pour supporter physiquement
les exigences du kart de haut niveau
sacrifices pour se rapprocher de ses
objectifs bref c'est d'être en f1 mais
c'est très difficile et donc pas déjà
être en automobile ces c'est déjà bien
mais c'est pour ça que parallèlement je
vais à l'école j'ai des très bons
résultats pour m'assurer monaco j'espère
qu'il va aller vers la monoplace et qui
va pouvoir s'épanouir dans le sport
automobile
je pense que c'est tout à fait possible
j'ai pas de bouc la plus chère aucun
doute oublier mme bertrand reprendra la
compétition en mars prochain son
objectif sera de terminer dans le top 3
au niveau national et enfin cette
dernière information le conseil
communautaire de log de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines prévue
initialement jeudi dernier mais annulée
aura lieu ce mercredi soir à 19h à
trappes c'est la fin de cette édition
tout de suite vous avez rendez vous avec
sephora namani pour un nouveau numéro de
kiosques quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain et je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée